[Music]
if you are looking for a day of fast fun
then look no further than spring
mountain motor resort and country club
in parump i pay them a visit in this
week's vegas drives
welcome to spring mountain motorsports
and country club today you're in for a
high horsepower treat come on
elizabeth thank you so much for having
us i'm super excited to be up here for
the first time what exactly happens up
here at spring mountain we are a private
country club for race car drivers
so
just like augusta national which is a
private country club for golfers instead
of golf we have instead of 18 holes of
golf we have 9.34 miles of racetrack now
someone's watching right now and they
just want to come up here for a day
maybe have a private lesson and learn
how to race a car pick up some racing
skills you guys offer that as well
absolutely yeah you know people can come
out and take one of our driving schools
or they can do a private lesson in their
own car if they have a race car that
they
can use on the track or if they want
they can use one of our cars we do offer
a couple of uh one-day schools can we
see some of the cars absolutely i'd love
to show them too i'll follow you
absolutely holy smokes these cars are
amazing what do we have these are uh
yeah these are some of our club members
cars as i said they do actually drive
their own cars here on track this right
here is a radical it's an english race
car this is not street legal so this is
strictly a race prepped car okay that
they will often use probably our largest
grid on our race weekends that we have
for our club members beautiful and we
also have some club members that enjoy
driving street legal cars like this
gorgeous gt3 this is amazing these cars
are beautiful
did they nice drive can i show everyone
a car can i go for a ride in the car
absolutely we'd love to take you for a
ride we're actually going to put you on
our brand new track which is charleston
peak
let's do it all right i'm ready for it
guys this is rick malone the chief
instructor it's good to see you buddy
guys jc how's it going great what are
you doing to me today today we're going
to take you out on our brand new 3.2
mile premiere race course one of the
best ones you're going to see in the
world and we're going to take you on the
new c8 corvette all right i think i'm
ready you ready i'm ready all right
let's go jc go easy on me
are you sure man
you ready to go all right here we go man
[Music]
and
there are houses here on the side of the
track yes if you're a member you can
purchase a lot and build a home on a lot
you can this is literally a golf course
by the car enthusiast exactly instead of
driving golf balls we drag cars yeah
your car's going all day as a car lover
right
sit in your backyard drink some coffee
and watch cars go every snap all day
long instead of fairways we have
straight away yes sir if you're looking
for something to do for a day trip or
become a member you got to come up here
to spring mountain thank you so much
rick you're welcome jc can we do it
again absolutely all right let's do it
again i'll see you guys later we're
gonna go do launch control
do it all day long up there it's a blast